- [Narrator] This is Jackson,
a 16-year-old golden eagle.
(gentle music)
We almost lost these beautiful birds,
but now they're bouncing back.
Golden eagles are excellent
hunters and extremely fast.
Diving at speeds greater
than 150 miles per hour,
this makes the golden eagle
one of the fastest animals on earth.
When hunting, they use their sharp talons
to grab their prey.
Golden eagles have been
known to hunt animals
as large as deer and gray wolves.
Their feathers are dark brown
with lighter golds around
their head and neck.
In the 1960s, ranchers
feared that they were eating
their livestock and over 20,000 were shot.
Since then, through education,
their numbers have re-stabilized
and their biggest threat
now is habitat loss.
This is the golden eagle.
(zooming ding)